can you just touch on the topic of
simulation do you find this thought
experiment that we're living in a
simulation useful inspiring a
constructive in any kind of way do you
think it's ridiculous do you think it
could be true or is it just a useful
thought experiment I think it is
extremely useful as a thought experiment
because it makes sense to everyone
especially as we see virtual reality and
computer games getting more and more
complex you're not talking to an
audience in like Newton's time where
you're like imagine a clock that it has
mechanics in it that are so complex that
it can create love and everyone's like
no but today you really start to feel
you know man
at what point is this little robot
friend of mine gonna be like someone I
don't want to cancel plans with yeah you
know and so it's a great the thought
experiment of do we live in a simulation
am i a brain and a bat that has just
been given electrical impulses from some
nefarious other beings so that I believe
that I live on earth and that I have a
body and all of this and the fact that
you can't prove it either way is a
fantastic way to introduce people to
some of the deepest questions
you